you
[Music]
today I'm gonna talk about a project
that I worked on at DN Co as a machine
learning engineer I just want to say
it's kind of cool to be in this place
here I actually spent six years at
Columbia in grad school and I think the
last time I was in this building I was
buying like discount movie tickets and
so it's fun to be back but before I get
into all of these buzz words up here and
I'm gonna get deep into them I gotta
explain what idea and code does so DN Co
is a personal styling service for
plus-sized women and what I'd like to
start out with is a quote to kind of
explain why this company exists and so
we have kind of this shocking statistic
that 70% of women in the US are
plus-sized but they only represent about
16% of apparel spend and so you have the
majority of US women and then definitely
a minority of dollars spent and so some
people might think that you know this is
just the way the market is these people
are not interested in purchasing clothes
and things like that but we are of the
opinion that that is totally not the
case and in fact the market has failed
this population and so that's where DN
Co comes in in order to kind of fill
this void and we do that through an
innovative business model so as a
personal science service first you come
to our website and you fill out a
profile about yourself where you tell us
what sorts of clothing you like what
sorts of clothing you don't like etc we
then have a human stylist go into kind
of like an internal ecommerce tool to
virtually pick out clothing to send to
you that they think that you will like
so we then send you five items of
clothing in a box you're then free to
try the clothing on in the comfort of
your own home whatever you like you keep
and pay for and whatever you don't like
you can send back to us shipping is free
that's all good and then if there's
things that you didn't like you can tell
us online if there's things that you did
like tell us that as well and then we
get better at understanding you and the
relationship gets better and so that's
kind of like the cordilla business model
and this stayed this way for
a couple years but then this past spring
we decided to try expanding our product
line and so the what we ended up
deciding to do was to ship boxes of
activewear so the cordilla product is
kind of everyday style clothes we
decided to build these active boxes so
this is both performance athletic wear
and athleisure wear and so the entire
process was the same you come and fill
out your profile five items in the box
and everything else but what this gave
us an opportunity to do as a business
was to kind of rethink all of the
processes in our business that have been
in place during the past couple of years
and so what we did was we actually
rebuilt everything from the ground up so
we built out a brand new survey that
customers fill out a brand new product
catalog and then we rethought the entire
styling process and so as the leader of
the styling data team this gave me a
chance to think through how do we do
things today and how can we do them
differently and better and so we ended
up on this very ambitious goal for
ourselves and that goal was to write an
algorithm to style all boxes for a given
day at once and to be clear we still
were going we still use human stylists
the difference here is that we run it to
write the algorithm to pre-fill the box
with five items and then the stylist
comes in and they're free to swap in
whatever they want in and out of the box
so kind of like this human-in-the-loop
approach that we just heard about in the
last session and so we were like all
right like we're gonna do this but you
might be asking why so what's the point
of pre filling the box when we still
have stylists who are doing doing the
job in the end and so the reason was
kind of twofold the first reason was
that blank canvases are kind of
difficult to start with so you can
imagine logging into Netflix and it's
just a blank page and then you have to
go in search and figure out what the
hell you feel like watching it's a lot
easier when you see these suggestions in
front of you as well for a stylist it's
a lot easier when they see a box of
clothing already there they can see an
outfit already there and then they're
free to modify this but perhaps the
bigger reason that we decided to go this
route we
that we have this problem of greedy
humans in the loop and what this problem
ends up doing is it creates inequality
across our customer base which is not a
good thing and so I'd like to kind of
explain how this inequality arises
through kind of a cartoon version of our
original product line and so let's
imagine this cartoon world where we have
one stylist and they have a queue of
boxes that they are going to style and
they're going to style each box one by
one in the order that they come in to in
the queue and let's also imagine that we
have a product catalog represented by
these emojis and these are all the
different products that we have
available to us and by all means all of
our products are great but you could
imagine that some of them are just
exceptional compared to the other ones
and so let's say that we have these
exceptional products that are the heart
eye emojis and our slightly smiling
emojis are all of our they're good
products but not exceptional
and so the stylist goes to style this
first box they look at the entire
product catalog and they're like oh look
at all those five awesome products I'm
gonna throw them all in this box because
I want this customer to be happy and
they do that and that's great for that
customer the problem is is that when the
next box comes in this customer now the
stylist doesn't have any of these
products to pick from they just have the
rest of the catalog and through kind of
no fault of this customer zone they just
happen to be second in line they end up
not getting any of these exceptional
products and so you can imagine if we
end up going through this process the
entire day we end up with one customer
who reaps all the spoils and then all
the other customers don't get this and
so that just doesn't feel fair and so a
better way to deal with is instead of
this kind of streaming fashion we can
pre distribute the wealth in our system
by doing a batch process and so that is
the goal of this algorithm is that the
algorithm is able to look across all of
the customers that day our entire
product catalog and it can optimize for
everybody's happiness not just one
individual
and so that way everybody gets one great
product and then they also get good
products as well and so that was really
the goal here around doing this and so
now that we have this kind of cartoon
version how do we actually do this in
practice we do this through combining
machine learning which probably lots of
you already know about if not I'm sure a
lot of people are going to talk about it
at this conference with operations
research which was spoken about at the
keynote it's just not as buzzword II
right now but it ends up being super
useful and so I kind of like to frame
these concepts around how they work at
businesses and in my mind the way that
all of these things work is their
various ways of automating decision
making at businesses through various
granularity of this decision making and
so starting at the left what I think of
analytics I think of being able to make
kind of like broad sweeping decisions
for a large group of people so let's
imagine that we're some company we send
out email marketing and we really want
to get our customers to open our emails
analytics can tell you it can help you
to make the decision that you know you
should be sending all your emails at 9
a.m. on Tuesdays because we've looked at
the historical data but we ran a sequel
query and we found that this is the time
when people are most likely to open
emails and so that that kind of gives us
like one big cut at the decision making
machine learning on the other hand
allows us to be hyper personalized and
allows us to make personalized decisions
on a one by one basis so maybe we will
look at every single customer we learn
when each of them are most likely to
open their emails and then we send
emails at times according to each
customer but this is still kind of on a
one-by-one basis at a business sometimes
you can't be as a like you can't keep
those horse blinders on like that you
have to look at the entire system as a
whole and so that's what operations
research allows us to do because there
might be constraints at your business it
could be that you need certain
deliverability of your emails to keep
your email service provider happy maybe
there's throughput in your system you
can't send all of your emails at nine am
on Tuesdays and operations research
allows us to kind of do
the constraints of a business and
optimize across the whole thing and so
maybe we would learn how do we
distribute our emails throughout the
week but then this is kind of unperson
alized right it's it's not really
optimizing for each person's likelihood
of opening and so that's where I think
things are really exciting is kind of
combining the two of these so operations
research allows us to consider all of
the constraints of the real world and a
machine learning allows us to really
optimize around what we want to what we
want to improve or what we want to you
know decrease so that's these concepts
kind of in in a general light I'm now
gonna walk through like an actual toy
example of how you yourself can build
your own box styling algorithm and so
that's using kind of a subset of
operations research which is called
integer programming and I'll explain why
it's called that in a little bit and if
there's kind of one thing that I want
you to take away from this talk it's
that if you want to set up any of these
problems you have to do these four steps
you have to do them in this order and if
you can do that then you can solve any
problem you want and I'm gonna walk
through each of the four steps and I'm
gonna start with the decision variables
these are the steps for how we build up
our problem and then how we solve it and
in order to do this I'm gonna commit
kind of the two cardinal sins of any
conference talk I'm gonna put math on
slides end code as well and so apologies
in advance but hopefully kind of like
one of these speaks to you
if not I'll keep speaking and if none of
that works and we can talk afterwards
during office hours so let's start with
our decision variables that we have to
define I'm gonna have the math on the
left and then I'll introduce the code on
the right and so what is our goal we
want to build an algorithm to figure out
which users in our system should receive
which items right so we have items which
are our clothing we have a user which
gets a box and we want to decide which
pieces of clothing should each user get
and so let's imagine we have kind of an
index of users we have an index of items
and then we are going to define two
decision variables so this is actually
what we're trying to solve for in our
model these are kind of the free
parameters and we want to write an
algorithm to
what values should these take so the
first one this is like a user indicator
variable what this does is it indicates
whether or not user you got a box so
whether or not our algorithm was able to
build a box for this customer if they're
able to get a box then they get a one if
they're not able to get a box then they
get a zero and that that's actually why
this is called integer programming
because you can't get half a box you can
either get no boxes or one box in the
way that we're setting up this problem
we have one more decision variable and
this is an indicator indicating whether
or not user you gets item I and so if we
if the algorithm decides that user u
gets item I then they get a 1 if the
algorithm decides that they don't get it
then they get a 0 and the goal of this
entire thing is to figure out what
should these values be for every user
which users get which items so let's
bring in some code which will maybe help
with this so everything I'm showing is
written in Python and it's using this
open source library called pulp so it's
completely free and it's a pretty great
library that allows you to define these
problems and solve them and so again we
have our users and our items and then
our user indicators this says for each
user we're gonna create an indicator
variable which is binary so it can be 0
or 1 and this is a pulp class and so
every user gets an indicator around
whether or not they got a box
likewise for every user and every item
there's an indicator variable saying did
they get this item or not so those are
decision variables again the goal is to
figure out what are the best values for
these to take and so how do we define
what best is that's where we define our
objective function and so the objective
function is going to be some function of
our decision variables that we either
want to maximize or minimize and so
maybe if you're at a business cost this
is probably a thing and maybe you want
to minimize cost or maybe you have an
objective function of profit which you
want to maximize in our case this is
where this is where we get to bring in
the machine learn
so imagine we have some score for every
user in every item so maybe we have the
the predicted probability of purchase we
train this fancy model to predict will
this customer buy this shirt we can
train that model ahead of time and we
can decide that our objective function
is just going to be the sum of all of
those purchased probabilities times
whether or not the customer got the item
or not so if the customer doesn't get
the item we don't add anything to our
objective function but if they receive
the item then we add in their predicted
probability of purchase and through this
we can maximize purchases you could also
imagine maximizing other things maybe we
want to maximize revenue which might be
the purchased probability times the cost
of the product or something like that
anyway in code the way that this works
is that you set up a problem in Pulp so
it's like very academic the way that
they wrote this code we have a problem
we want to solve it this is a
maximization problem you can also define
minimization problems but we want to
maximize purchases not minimize them
great way to minimize purchases is you
don't build a box for anybody can't buy
it if they don't get it and so the way
that our objective function works is
that we basically just aggregate
everything up into a list so all of our
scores times whether or not the customer
got it aggregate this whole list sum it
all up and then we add it to our problem
which is kind of just the way that the
the Pulte API works so we have our
decision variables that's what we want
to solve for now we want to know how we
want to solve we want to maximize
purchases the last step are the
constraints in the problem because
sometimes like the real world gets in
the way of our problems that we work on
and so there's only two constraints in
this problem I'll show both the math
here and the code at once
this top constraint all this is saying
is that every customer if they get a box
they have to get five items if they
don't get a box they can't get anything
and so the way that that works is for
each user we can add up all of the items
that they got by summing up their
indicators and if they get a box this is
gonna be one yes they got the box that's
a 1 1 times 5 is 5
two-five has to be equal to five so this
is something that we're telling our
algorithm if they get a box then they
have to get five items if they don't get
a box if this is a zero zero has to be
equal to zero therefore they don't get
any items so this defines how big our
boxes down here this is just saying that
we can't use more products than we have
in stock right now and so how do we know
how many products were using well for
each item we can add up all the users
that got the products and then we can
say that that sum has to be less than or
equal to however many we have in stock
right now and so that's kind of where
the real world comes in I'd love it if
we had infinite products but but we
don't and so this way we can add in real
world constraints endure a problem okay
and then the last point we have our
decision variables we want to maximize
purchases we have the constraints of the
real world now we have to solve the
problem and frankly I don't have a great
handle on how the math works but
wonderfully these algorithms provide you
this great little method you just hit
solve and they crunch away and then
you're like great because it was already
a lot of work just to get to this point
and so it's it's nice to at least have
this part solved for you and so that's
it we're through with the math in the
code if you follow that great if not
doesn't matter because we're gonna kind
of switch gears so now I want to talk
about how do we go from kind of this toy
model that we've built this you know
this academic code that lives on our
computer into something that is
productionize or production alized
i've heard both and i don't I feel like
our industry is not landed on where
these which term is correct both always
end up triggering the spellchecker and
so probably neither are correct and so
the rest of the talk is just going to be
about how do we make this thing
automatically and reliably run in the
cloud and so that kind of starts to get
into the the data inge part i guess of
this talk and so I feel like there's
about five key areas that allow us to do
this and that we did when we built this
out at Diaa and co and so the first one
is defining good software architecture
and so one thing that helped me was to
kind of define to
print like concepts within the code and
these are deterministic concepts and
stochastic concepts and so deterministic
what I mean in this context is these are
things that are known ahead of time like
prior to building up your optimization
problem stochastic these are kind of
functions of the problem themselves and
I'll explain this in more detail and so
let's start with how we think of these
concepts around our objective function
and so before I get to that though I
have to let you guys in on a little
secret I've been talking about how we
can use machine learning and all of
these fancy things but when we launch
this product line we actually had no
data it was a brand new product line
nobody had ever bought anything so it's
really hard to predict probability as a
participant you have no training data
and so what we ended up doing was we
kind of cheated a little bit we
basically just made up a bunch of rules
and we assign point values to them and
so an example of one of these rules
might be we decided all right if this
item is within the customers budget then
that customer gets 50 points if they get
that item and so that's actually really
easy to handle in this because we know
the customers budget upfront we know the
cost of the item upfront and so we can
kind of pre calculate all of this and
aggregate all of our points up into a
score for this item how much is this
worth for this customer that's pretty
easy a much harder score that we came up
with was something like if the customer
gets an outfit where maybe the outfit is
some particular top that goes with a
skirt then the customer gets a hundred
points the problem is we don't know this
ahead of time because that's literally
what we're trying to solve for is what
is the customer going to get and so this
is actually it ends up being fairly
difficult but it turns out that you can
solve this by kind of creating your own
mini optimization problem so you define
new decision variables saying did the
customer get an outfit or not we define
constraints around deciding how do we
know if they got the outfit or not and
then we can kind of add this into our
objective function but ends up being
kind of an entire sub problem within the
problem and one tip for experts in the
audience is a good way to do this is to
use this thing called the big end method
you it's actually a real thing you can
google it there's a whole Wikipedia page
about it
and that worked quite nicely for us to
set these up we can now move over to the
constraint side of things so what are
the deterministic constraints that we
know ahead of time an example is users
can't get items that don't fit them that
that's a pretty obvious one and the nice
thing is that we know there's ahead of
time we know the size of the product we
know the size of the customer and so an
easy way to solve this is you just don't
make those decision variables if the
computer never has the option to give
the customer this product then they're
never going to get it and kind of
another another pro tip for this is that
when you stop making some of these
decisions very Abele's you end up with
this kind of weird sparse matrix between
users and items and graph structures end
up working out pretty well for keeping
track of these relationships stochastic
constraints these are kind of the ones
that I was talking about before so an
example might be customers must receive
between x and y shirts maybe we have a
minimum and maximum number of shirts
that they have to get in their box and
unfortunately there's kind of no real
way around this you end up having to do
the mental gymnastics and the math that
I showed before in order to define these
but kind of once you started to solve a
couple of these you start to figure out
the tricks of how to do other ones and
so one thing that helped was that when
we define these kind of concepts that I
was talking about before you end up kind
of creating these isolated pieces of
code so for example every type of score
that we have we created a class for and
every type of constraint that we had we
created a class for and that actually
helps you out a lot when you end up in
moving into testing your code but one
thing is that unit tests are super hard
for these types of problems it's really
hard to write like a unit test for some
constraint function which is this weird
inequality and everything else and so
what we end up doing more is testing for
behavior and so maybe for a particular
constraint if we want to test it we
might solve a very quick tiny
optimization problem with and without
constraint and then we make sure that
that constraint is satisfied for
different inputs and in order to do that
in a nice way it really helps to invest
in some test setup functions so writing
some functions which allow you to
quickly create tiny optimization
problems or quickly basically run your
pipeline because like everything in data
science I feel like ends up being a
pipeline and so if you can quickly set
up your pipeline then you can test it
also if you can quickly set it up then
your code is probably in a good place so
now that we have good code or good
enough code we have tests now how does
this kind of software end up interfacing
with the rest of our tech ecosystem and
so one thing that we've found helpful at
the Enco is building micro services and
really isolating kind of the core
Coppins competency of the code in
different places and so what we ended up
doing is we didn't want to have to
consider all sorts of extraneous
business logic in this optimization
algorithm so for example I don't want to
have to you know maintain the code that
decides how many units do we have in
inventory or like maintain the code that
decides which boxes do we need a style
today and so what we end up doing is we
kind of have our isolated optimization
algorithm over here and all of our
inventory information is stored in
elasticsearch and we can just send quick
get requests to pull down product data
and kind of like the real-time state of
our inventory and then we in order to
figure out which boxes we need a style
we had our dev team build out a very
lightweight API and all I got to do is
say hey what boxes do I have to style I
pull down the information I run the
algorithm and then we send patch
requests back which basically update the
contents of these boxes and that way you
know it was already enough work to get
this whole thing running and we don't
have to know about the rest of the
system so that all sounded nice and good
as though everything always goes great
but of course things don't always go
great things break and things did break
and so one thing that helps is being
able to plan around failures and because
failures are inevitable and so
kind of two things helped me out with
this one was that kind of the default
mode of these algorithms is to solve
them to the best possible solution so if
we want to maximize purchases it's gonna
find really like the theoretical maximum
purchase sum for the whole algorithm but
remember I said that we kind of like
made up these points and things like
that and so the difference between you
know point 0 0 1 percent and 1 percent
of the theoretical maximum is probably
just noise at this point and so one
thing that helped was don't require the
algorithm to you know perfectly solve
the problem within 1% is probably pretty
great already and so that helped the
other thing that helped was we figured
out that these stochastic scores that I
talked about those really slowed the
algorithm down if we remove them we
could really quickly solve and get a
good solution and so what we end up
doing now is we actually solve a simpler
version of our problem which is still a
valid solution it still satisfies all of
our business constraints and then now we
have a minimum viable solution and then
we can pass that in as a starting point
for solving the more complicated version
of our problem and so one were
guaranteed a viable solution and then
two it turns out having a good starting
point really helps these algorithms to
solve faster and so both of these really
really helped us to make sure that we
were able to style boxes every single
day and now that we have all of this set
up like how do we end up iterating on
this because it's very rare that kind of
the first time that you build a an
algorithm that it's really the best and
then you just leave it and walk away and
so one thing that helps to iterate is to
be able to frequently deploy and really
run code in production and so we use
kind of a whole host of different
services to do this everything is
containerized with docker so that our
local development matches cloud
deployment as much as possible
everything runs through circle CI so
that all of our tests are required to
pass and then everything gets
automatically deployed and then we kind
of use these various cloud services to
kind of you know abstract away the cloud
infrastructure and just
the code run without us having to
maintain it too much once we have all of
that in place how do we end up improving
this model so one thing that I did was i
sat down with kind of the domain experts
at my company like the people that are
on the merchandising team in the styling
team and we just stared at things so we
had no data to work with or anything
else and so instead we would just run
the algorithm look at boxes that came
out of the algorithm look at customers
profiles and then we just kind of tweak
our point values and tune the knobs a
little bit until we saw things that
satisfy the domain experts and so that
was like a nice place to start but it's
not very scientific and so that's when
we have to turn to the ridiculous world
of machine learning and so with that
what we decided to do was instead of
having these points let us learn what is
the best value for these points to take
and so the way to do that is we decided
to turn these points in our system you
know if you get an item in your budget
it's 50 points or whatever turn that
into an actual coefficient of a machine
learning model and so the way that this
works is that each of these rules and
points that we made up those become a
feature in our machine learning model
the observation or the sample in our
machine learning data set is going to be
an individual box and then we are going
to learn a function to map these
features in order to predict some box
level metrics so maybe it's like a
number of purchases in the box 0 through
5 maybe it's like total revenue that we
make off of this box and so the way this
ends up working is we have our feature
matrix X down here we're gonna learn
some weights
and then we're gonna have create some
function that ends up predicting some
box level metrics and I guess just a
quick shout out here I haven't done any
of this so I passed the project on with
with the the hand-tuned points to
credly who's another machine learning
engineer at DM co and he has now built
out the machine learning layer that
lives on top of all of this and so the
way the sense of working is that each
row is going to be an individual box we
have our features which is like is there
an outfit in the box or not or how many
items were within budget so we have to
aggregate everything up to the box level
we're gonna learn weights so this is
like how how much is it worth for there
to be an outfit in the box how much is
it worth for there to be items within
our budget and then we're gonna learn
these weights such that we're able to
predict some business metric let's say
it's a number of items kept if we can
learn these weights then we can feed
them into our objective function and
really maximize for purchases or for
revenue in a way that is kind of
quantitatively sound then other nice
thing is that in order to build this you
end up getting a pretty interpretable
model remember we like we sat down and
created all of our features by hand
which we all probably should be doing
when we design machine learning
algorithms but oftentimes you just shove
a bunch of stuff in there and then hope
that your metrics look good but in this
case it ends up being a lot of work to
define this all in the optimization
problem and so you end up being fairly
conservative in how you build your
features and then the other thing is
that all of this has to be a linear
model for it to work with these
optimization algorithms and so on the on
the one hand you don't get to use deep
learning or random forests or anything
like that you basically you just have to
use regression but on the other hand
because you're doing that because you've
spent a lot of time you're now learning
really kind of like how important are
each of these features and then we can
also use that to inform our stylist and
tell them you know why did the algorithm
think that this that the customer would
like this item we now have an
interpretable model and we can surface
that up to them so if any of that
sounded interesting to you then I'd be
happy to talk afterwards about this I've
also written some blog posts about
optimization problems if you didn't get
enough math there and then I if you're
interested in any of these types of
problems or in other problems we work on
a lot of them
definitely hiring for data engineering
rolls machine learning rolls etc and
there is a booth downstairs where you
can talk with other people from the
company so thank you gotcha
so I would say the product catalog is
let's say tens of thousands of products
but we can kind of call this down ahead
of time because you know we're not gonna
select from products that don't fit a
customer certain things might not be in
stock and things like that yeah so we
haven't we haven't done any segmentation
of our customers or anything for the
machine learning component basically
what we wanted to start with was I have
always wondered what should these point
values have been because I just tweaked
them by hand and so that's really where
we've started it out is let us learn the
best values for the points and then
we're gonna start adding more features
in iterating on that and things like
that yeah yeah so some of the things
like actually the outfit one that was a
major pain to figure out how to code
that up and it turns out at least as far
as we've been able to tell so far it's
not so important to have that in there
and so it's like nice to know now but I
would have liked to know that ahead of
time yeah so the question was around the
fact that we're able to get good results
for the open source software and was
that because of the software was that
because of kind of us figuring things
out so the software is pretty good pulp
is kind of an API that hooks up to
different solving libraries so Paul
pandals the first three steps in that
pipeline the solving part that I don't
know anything about that's handled by
other libraries and we use this library
called coin which is free and is about
the best free library you can get for
integer programming I would say that we
were able to get good results because I
ended up spending a fair amount of time
doing things like solving simple
versions of the problem and feeding that
in the libraries are okay but there is
there are proprietary libraries that are
pretty expensive and they are like
orders of magnitude better than the open
source ones so it's very different than
the world of like deep learning where
tensorflow is free and everybody enjoys
it optimization algorithms are still
kind of in
closed-source area yeah so it's kind of
hard to do that and so we basically
we've been looking at a number of
different metrics so one thing is we
know exactly what the algorithm puts
into the box and then we know what the
stylus chooses to send to the customer
and then we know what does the customer
keep how do they rate the items and
things like that and so you can kind of
think of a thing whole thing like a
funnel so what should our algorithm like
what is our goal the goal would be for
the algorithm to basically place items
in the box that the stylist is like yeah
that's a great idea and then the
customer keeps it and so we can look at
metrics like how often our stylist
swapping things out for things that they
swap out is the customer more or less
likely to keep these items and things
like that
and so that that's one way the other
ways you can run a be test and so an
example would be maybe half the boxes
that they the algorithm styles and half
the boxes we have somebody Heymann style
and then you can kind of compare these
results we haven't run those a/b tests
though
[Music]